¡Gracias! Es un gran honor y un privilegio estar aquí
pasando mi último día de adolescente.
Hoy les quiero hablar sobre el futuro, pero
primero les voy a contar algo sobre el pasado.
Mi historia empieza mucho antes de que yo naciera.
Mi abuela estaba en un tren a Auschwitz, el campo de concentración.
Iba a lo largo de las vías del tren, y las vías se dividieron.
Y de alguna forma -- no sabemos exactamente toda la historia -- pero
el tren tomó la vía equivocada y fue a un campo de trabajo en vez de un campo de muerte.
Mi abuela sobrevivió y se casó con mi abuelo.
Se fueron a vivir a Hungría, y nació mi madre.
Y cuando mi madre tenía dos años,
la revolución húngara estaba causando estragos, y decidieron escapar de Hungría.
Tomaron un barco, y he aquí otra división --
el barco iba o a Canadá o a Australia.
Abordaron y no supieron a dónde iban, y acabaron en Canadá.
Así que, en resumen, acabaron en Canadá.
Mi abuela fue una química. Trabajó en el instituto Banting de Toronto,
y a los 44 años murió de cáncer de estómago. Nunca conocí a mi abuela,
pero llevo su nombre -- su nombre exacto, Eva Vertes --
y me gusta pensar que llevo también su pasión científica.
Encontré esta pasión no muy lejos de aquí, de hecho, cuándo tenía nueve años.
Mi familia emprendió un viaje en automóvil y llegamos al Gran Cañón.
Y yo nunca había sido lectora de pequeña --
mi padre había intentado iniciarme con los Hardy Boys, yo probé con Nancy Drew,
probé todo eso -- y simplemente no me gustaba leer libros.
Y mi madre trajo un libro cuando estábamos en el Gran Cañón
llamado "La Zona Caliente." Trataba sobre de un brote del virus del Ébola.
Y algo en el libro hizo que me sintiera atraída hacia él.
Había un gran virus de forma irregular en la portada,
y me dieron muchas ganas de leerlo. Tomé ese libro,
y mientras íbamos desde el borde del Gran Cañón
hacia Big Sur, y hasta, de hecho, aquí -- donde estamos hoy en Monterey --
leí ese libro, y desde que empecé a leerlo,
supe que quería dedicarme a la medicina.
Quería ser como los exploradores sobre los que leía en el libro,
que iban a las junglas de África,
iban a laboratorios de investigación y trataban de averiguar
lo que era este virus letal. Así que desde ese momento, leí cada libro médico
que lograba encontrar, y me gustaban muchísimo.
Era una observadora pasiva del mundo médico.
Y cuando entré al bachillerato pensé:
"Quizás ahora,-- que soy toda una bachiller --
quizás me pueda volver una parte activa de este gran mundo médico."
Tenía 14 años, y le escribí por correo electrónico a profesores de la universidad local
para ver si quizás podría ir a trabajar a su laboratorio. Y casi ninguno respondió.
Pero claro, ¿por qué habrían de responderle a una niña de 14 años?
Y logré ir a hablar con un profesor, el Dr. Jacobs,
que me aceptó dentro del laboratorio.
En ese entonces, yo estaba muy interesada en la neurociencia
y quería hacer un proyecto de investigación en neurología --
específicamente observando los efectos de metales pesados en el sistema nervioso en desarrollo.
Así empecé, y trabajé en su laboratorio durante un año,
y encontré los resultados que supongo puede uno esperar
cuando alimentas a moscas de la fruta con metales pesados -- es decir, encuentras sistemas nerviosos muy, muy deteriorados.
La columna vertebral tenía rupturas. Las neuronas se cruzaban sin ningún orden.
Y de ahí quería mirar no al deterioro, sino a la prevención del deterioro.
Así que eso fue lo que me condujo hacia el Alzheimer. Empecé a leer sobre el Alzeheimer
y traté de familiarizarme con la investigación,
y al mismo tiempo cuando estaba en la --
estaba leyendo en la librería médica un día, y leí este artículo
acerca de algo llamado derivados de purina.
Y parecían tener propiedades de estimulación del crecimiento celular.
Y sin saber mucho sobre el campo, pensé algo así como,
"Ah, tienes muerte celular en el Alzheimer
que está causando el déficit de memoria, y luego tienes este compuesto --
los derivados de purina -- que promueven el crecimiento celular."
Y entonces pensé, "Quizás si puedo promover el crecimiento celular,
esto podría inhibir la muerte celular, también."
Y ese fue el proyecto en el que trabajé durante ese año,
y continúa ahora todavía,
y descubrí que un derivado de purina específico llamado guanidina
había inhibido el crecimiento celular en aproximadamente el 60%.
Así que presenté estos resultados en la Feria Internacional de la Ciencia,
que fue una de las experiencias más maravillosas de mi vida.
Y ahí me fue otorgado el premio "Mejor del Mundo en Medicina",
que me permitió entrar, o al menos poner un pie en la puerta del gran mundo médico.
Y a partir de entonces, puesto que ya estaba en este mundo enorme y emocionante,
quería explorarlo todo. Lo quería todo de una vez, pero sabía que eso no era posible.
Y me tropecé con algo llamado células madres cancerosas.
Y esto es sobre lo que les quiero hablar hoy -- sobre el cáncer.
Al principio, cuando oí hablar de las células madres cancerosas,
no sabía cómo hacer para combinar los dos conceptos. Había oído hablar de células madre,
como si fueran la panacea del futuro --
la futura terapia contra muchas enfermedades, quizás.
Pero había oído hablar del cáncer como la más temida enfermedad de nuestro tiempo,
así que ¿cómo es que iban juntos lo bueno con lo malo?
El verano pasado trabajé en la universidad de Stanford, haciendo investigaciones sobre las células madre cancerosas.
Y mientras tanto, estaba leyendo la literatura sobre el cancer,
intentando -- de nuevo -- familiarizarme con este nuevo campo médico.
Y parecía que los tumores en realidad nacen de una célula madre.
Y eso me fascinó. Entre más leía, más empezaba a mirar el cáncer de una forma diferente
y empezó a darme menos miedo.
Parece que el cáncer es el resultado directo de una lesión.
Si fumas, lesionas tu tejido pulmonar, y el cáncer pulmonar aparece.
Si bebes alcohol, lesionas tu hígado, y el cáncer de hígado se desarrolla.
Y era realmente interesante -- había artículos mostrando la correlación
de cómo si tienes una fractura de hueso, el cáncer de hueso aparece.
Porque lo que las células madres son -- son estas
células fenomenales que realmente tienen la capacidad de diferenciarse
en cualquier tipo de tejido.
Así, si el cuerpo detecta que tienes daño en un órgano
y luego está iniciando cáncer, es casi como si esto fuera una respuesta curativa.
Y el cáncer, el cuerpo, está diciendo que el tejido pulmonar está dañado,
necesitamos reparar el pulmón. Y el cáncer se origina en ese pulmón
que trata de repararse -- porque tienes esta excesiva proliferación
de estas células extraordinarias que tienen el potencial de convertirse en tejido pulmonar.
Pero es casi como si el cuerpo hubiera inventado esta respuesta ingeniosa,
pero no puede controlarla muy bien.
Todavía no se ha vuelto lo suficientemente preciso para terminar lo que inició.
Entonces esto realmente me fascinó.
Y creo que no podemos pensar en el cáncer --
por no mencionar cualquier enfermedad -- en términos tan de blanco y negro.
Si eliminamos el cáncer de la forma en que intentamos hacerlo ahora, con quimioterapia y radiación,
estamos bombardeando el cuerpo o el cáncer con toxinas, o con radiación, intentando matarlo.
Es casi como si estuviéramos regresando al punto de partida.
Estamos eliminando las células cancerosas, pero estamos revelando el daño anterior
que el cuerpo ha intentado reparar.
¿Acaso no deberíamos pensar en manipulación, más que eliminación?
Si de alguna forma podemos hacer que estas células se diferencien --
y se vuelvan tejido de hueso, tejido de pulmón, tejido de hígado,
para lo que sea que el cáncer ha sido puesto ahí --
sería un proceso de reparación. Acabaríamos mejor que como estábamos antes del cáncer.
Esto cambió totalmente mi forma de ver el cáncer.
Y mientras leía todos estos artículos sobre el cáncer,
parecía que los artículos -- muchos de ellos -- se enfocaban
en la genética del cáncer de pecho. Y en la génesis
y progresión del cáncer de pecho --
rastreando el cáncer a través del cuerpo, dónde esta, y a dónde va.
Pero lo que me sorprendió fue que nunca había oído hablar del cáncer de corazón,
o cáncer de cualquier músculo esquelético, de hecho.
Y el músculo esquelético constituye el 50% de nuestro cuerpo,
o más del 50 por ciento de nuestro cuerpo. Así que al principio pensé algo así como,
"Bueno, quizás haya una explicación obvia
de por qué el músculo esquelético no desarrolla cáncer -- al menos no que yo sepa."
Así que seguí ahondando en el tema, encontré tantos artículos como pude,
y era sorprendente -- porque resultó que era muy raro.
Algunos artículos se atrevían a decir incluso que el tejido de músculo esquelético
es resistente al cáncer, y lo que es más, no sólo al cáncer,
sino también a que la metástasis lo invada.
Y lo que las metástasis son es cuando el tumor --
cuando una pieza -- se separa y viaja a través del torrente sanguíneo
y va a un órgano diferente. Eso es una metástasis.
Es la parte más peligrosa del cáncer.
Si el cáncer permaneciera en un sólo lugar, probablemente podríamos eliminarlo,
o de alguna forma -- está contenido. Está muy contenido.
Pero una vez que empieza a moverse a lo largo del cuerpo, entonces es cuando se vuelve letal.
El hecho era entonces que no sólo el cáncer no parecía originarse en los músculos esqueléticos,
sino que el cáncer no parecía ir al músculo esquelético en absoluto --
parecía haber algo ahí.
Entonces estos artículos decían:
la metástasis del músculo esquelético -- es muy rara."
Pero se quedaba en eso. Nadie parecía preguntarse el porqué.
Así que decidí investigar por qué. Al principio -- lo primero que hice
fue mandarle correos electrónicos a varios profesores
especialistas en fisiología del músculo esquelético, y lo que les decía era,
"Oiga, parece que el cáncer no va al músculo esquelético,
¿hay alguna razón para esto?" Y muchas de las respuestas que recibí fueron
que el músculo es tejido diferenciado terminalmente.
Lo que significa que tienes células musculares, pero no se están dividiendo,
así que no parecen ser un buen candidato para que el cáncer las secuestre.
Pero al mismo tiempo, este hecho de que la metástasis
no fuera para el músculo esquelético hacía que eso fuera poco probable.
Y aún más, al tejido nervioso -- al cerebro -- le da cáncer,
y las células cerebrales también se diferencian terminalmente.
Así que decidí investigar por qué. Y aquí están algunas de, digamos, mis hipótesis
que empezaré a investigar este mayo en el instituto de cáncer Sylvester en Miami
E imagino que seguiré investigando hasta que obtenga las respuestas.
Pero sé que en la ciencia, una vez que tienes las respuestas,
inevitablemente te van a surgir más preguntas.
Así que creo que podría decirse que probablemente voy a hacer esto por el resto de mi vida.
Algunas de mis hipótesis son que
cuándo piensas por primera vez en el músculo esquelético,
hay muchos vasos sanguíneos que van al músculo esquelético.
Y la primera cosa que eso me hace pensar es que
los vasos sanguíneos son como carreteras para las células de un tumor.
Las células de un tumor pueden viajar a través de los vasos sanguíneos.
Y uno pensaría, entre más carreteras haya en un tejido,
es más probable que desarrolle cáncer o metástasis.
Entonces en primer lugar pensé, "¿No le sería favorable
al cáncer ir al músculo esquelético?" Y asimismo,
los tumores de cáncer requieren un proceso llamado angiogénesis,
que consiste en realidad, en que el tumor recluta los vasos sanguíneos para sí mismo,
para suplirse a sí mismo de nutrientes para poder crecer.
Sin angiogénesis, el tumor permanece del tamaño de la punta de un alfiler y no es dañino.
Así que la angiogénesis es realmente un proceso central en el desarrollo del cáncer como enfermedad.
Y un artículo que me llamó mucho la atención
cuándo estaba leyendo sobre todo esto, intentando entender por qué el cáncer no iba al músculo
esquelético, fue uno donde se informaba de un 16 por ciento de micro-metástasis
en el músculo esquelético bajo autopsia.
¡16 por ciento! Lo que significa que hay este tipo de tumores minúsculos en el músculo esquelético,
pero sólo un 0,16% de verdaderas metástasis --
lo que sugiere que quizás el músculo esquelético sea capaz de controlar la angiogénesis,
sea capaz de controlar que los tumores recluten vasos sanguíneos.
Usamos muchísimo los músculos esqueléticos. Es la única parte de nuestro cuerpo --
nuestro corazón siempre está latiendo. Siempre estamos moviendo los músculos.
¿Será posible que el músculo de alguna forma sepa intuitivamente
que necesita este suministro sanguíneo? Necesita estar contrayéndose constantemente,
así que por eso es casi egoísta. Arrebatando todos los vasos sanguíneos para sí mismo.
Por eso, cuando un tumor viene al tejido del músculo sanguíneo,
no puede obtener un suministro de sangre, y por lo tanto no crece.
Así que esto sugiere que quizás, si hay un factor anti-angiogénico
en el músculo esquelético -- o quizás aun más,
un factor que dirija la angiogénesis, que de hecho dirija dónde han de crecer los vasos sanguíneos --
esto podría ser una posible terapia futura contra el cáncer.
Y otra cosa que es muy interesante es que
hay todo este -- la forma en que los tumores se mueven a lo largo del cuerpo
es un sistema muy complejo -- y hay algo llamado la red quemoquina.
Y las quemoquinas son esencialmente atractores químicos,
son los semáforos del cáncer.
Un tumor expresa receptores quemoquinos,
y otro órgano -- un órgano distante en alguna parte del cuerpo --
va a tener las quemoquinas correspondientes,
y el tumor va a ver estas quemoquinas y va a migrar hacia él.
¿Será posible que el músculo esquelético no exprese este tipo de moléculas?
Y la otra cosa realmente interesante es que
cuando el músculo esquelético -- ha habido varios reportes de que cuando el músculo
esquelético se daña, es eso lo que se correlaciona con que la metástasis vaya al músculo esquelético.
Y, aún más, cuando el músculo esquelético se daña,
eso es lo que causa que las quemoquinas -- estas señales diciendo,
"Cáncer, puedes venir a mí," los semáforos verdes para los tumores --
esto causa que expresen en gran cantidad estas quemoquinas.
Así que, hay muchas cosas interactuando aquí.
Es decir, hay tantas posibilidades
que pueden explicar por qué los tumores no van al músculo esquelético.
Pero pareciera que investigando, atacando al cáncer,
buscando dónde no está el cáncer, tiene que haber algo --
tiene que haber algo -- que está haciendo este tejido resistente a los tumores.
¿Y será posible utilizar -- será posible tomar esta propiedad,
este compuesto, este receptor, lo que sea que este controlando estas
propiedades anti-tumor y aplicarlas a la terapia contra el cáncer en general?
Ahora, una cosa que en cierta forma relaciona la resistencia del músculo esquelético al cáncer --
con la idea del cáncer como un mecanismo de respuesta del cuerpo fuera de control --
es que el músculo esquelético tiene un factor en él llamado MyoD.
Y lo que el MyoD hace en esencia es causar que las células se diferencien
en células musculares. Así que este compuesto, MyoD,
ha sido probado en muchos tipos de células diferentes y se ha visto cómo
convierte toda esta variedad de tipos de célula en células de músculo esquelético.
Entonces, ¿será posible que las células del tumor estén yendo al tejido del músculo esquelético,
pero una vez en contacto dentro del tejido del músculo esquelético,
el MyoD actúa sobre estas células del tumor y causa
que se conviertan en células de músculo esquelético?
Quizás las células del tumor se estén disfrazando de células del músculo esquelético,
y sea por esto por lo que parece tan raro el cáncer en ellas.
Aquí no es dañino, sino que ha repararado el músculo.
El músculo está siendo usado constantemente -- está siendo constantemente lesionado.
Si cada vez que nos desgarráramos un músculo
o cada vez que estiráramos un músculo o nos moviéramos de forma incorrecta,
ocurriera el cáncer -- pues, tendría cáncer casi todo el mundo.
Y detesto decirlo. Pero parece como si las células musculares,
posiblemente por todo su uso, se han adaptado
más rápidamente que los otros tejidos del cuerpo para responder a la lesión,
para calibrar su respuesta de reparación y ser capaces de terminar el proceso
que el cuerpo quiere llevar a cabo. Realmente creo que el cuerpo humano es muy,
muy inteligente, y no podemos contrarrestar algo que el cuerpo está diciendo que se haga.
Es diferente cuando una bacteria entra al cuerpo,
ese es un objeto externo -- lo queremos fuera.
Pero cuando el cuerpo es en realidad el que está iniciando un proceso
y le llamamos a eso enfermedad, no parece que la eliminación sea
la solución correcta. Así que incluso partiendo de ahí, es posible -- aunque es una hipótesis increíble ahora --
que en el futuro casi pudiéramos pensar en usar el cáncer como terapia.
Si esas enfermedades donde los tejidos se deterioran --
por ejemplo, el Alzheimer, donde el cerebro, las células cerebrales, mueren
y necesitamos restaurar nuevas células cerebrales, nuevas células cerebrales funcionales --
¿qué tal si pudiéramos, en el futuro, usar el cáncer? Un tumor --
¿ponerlo en el cerebro y hacerlo diferenciarse en células cerebrales?
Esa es una idea muy arriesgada e increíble ahora, pero realmente creo que puede ser posible.
Estas células son tan versátiles, estas células de cáncer son tan versátiles --
que sólo tenemos que manipularlas de la forma correcta.
Y de nuevo, parte de esto puede ser arriesgado y sonar increíble, pero
creo que si hay algún lugar para presentar ideas arriesgadas es aquí en TED, así que
muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)